if they called you again they wanted to
do they want to do another harry potter
she's written another book my wife asked
me that a week ago
what would you do she asked me because
there were there was that
that news thing that she showed me about
how they're talking about apparently
they're working on
they're working on some tv series it's
probably i'm pretty sure it's
or at least like or at least like all it
is is like some guy in an office went
hey we should make a harry potter show
and
yeah we should do that and that's
literally the limit of the story
um but anyway it's big news it's global
it's everywhere it's viral
um because it's harry potter um and my
wife was like would you do it if if they
asked you and i
i don't know um i can't confess to have
given it some see
any serious thought but um i don't know
i uh
i don't have a desire to do it let's put
let's put it that way
um like there's obviously many many
factors when it comes to
to whether you're gonna take a job on or
not i mean let's be honest
we're we can claim to be artists
all day long but we're just
professionals and if you know if the
money's right then you'll probably do a
lot of things
um that's such a huge epic thing in
in terms of wanting to go back to that
character
i would genuinely have to say it would
have i mean this is me purely
speculating it's not going to be about
that i'm not going to ask me or anything
like that
but if they did hypothetically i would
have to read
i would have to read everything i'd have
to know exactly what it was who was
doing it
you know i'd always said to my wife you
remember when they did like save by the
bell the new class
and it was just mr belding it's like i
don't want to be mr belding
i mean well hang on here's what's great
if they did it think about this
they probably put a little suit on you
so you look a little heavier
you'd probably they could mess your
teeth up you could look a little bit
different
you can gain some weight for the roll
and you could look not like you again
so you go back to something that you
trans form
transformation i just
i just don't know if i tell you one
thing about talking about the
my absolute favorite thing about being
an actor right
is the fact that and i don't know if you
have a similar kind of thing
but the the thing with me is i've never
really excelled at
anything like sport or um
academia like i was i've basically been
fine at everything like i'm not really
bad at anything
um i'm just fine at loads of stuff i can
do loads of stuff too hard on yourself
um
and so the thing with acting is that
i've never actually had to choose
sit and and choose a profession because
with acting i can
i can do all kinds of different mad
like i can play soldiers i can play
police officers i can play
wizards i can you know whatever the role
takes i get to adopt a whole new
lifestyle and a new uh i get to play
dress-up you know i get to get in
costume and
play make believe and then when i've
done with that i get to move on and do a
different one
i've got a really short attention span
and and i get bored really easily with
stuff
and uh and and i'm i'm really good at uh
focusing all my energy into something
for a really short space of time like
i will i will get when i'm on when i'm
on something that i that i'm enjoying
i'll be like
i'll be obsessed with it i'll be
obsessive i'll wake up in the morning
i'll be upset i'll be like
first thing i think about i want to do
it do it do it and after about a week
i go yeah i'm bored now and i'll move on
which with the
with with with acting is so great for me
because i can be
fully invested in a role for a couple of
months
and then i go yeah i'm done with that
now i get to go and do a different one
and it just keeps it fresh all the time
and exciting and
and uh i guess off the back of being in
harry potter for 10 years
i really enjoy the freedom of being able
to do that
and um and i have kind of shied away
from a lot of
um roles and and stuff that have
that have been oh this could potentially
be another seven years and i'm just